[SPEAKER_02]: Basically you have these two guys, three of them got away.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just in case.
[SPEAKER_00]: They might be good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, we got the two.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sit the guy in the chair.
[SPEAKER_02]: So basically you sit the guy in the chair and there are people sitting around watching you guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm looting the other dude.
[SPEAKER_01]: The big guy?
[SPEAKER_01]: The big guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, he's got a pouch of coins.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's got 50 coins on him.
[SPEAKER_02]: The rapier is nice and he's got a nicely made dagger.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Take the dagger, the rapier, and the coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everyone's looking.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just going to go sit down and look at the coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: People are watching you.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're gold coins.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're principality coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many are in there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Roughly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fifty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fifty?
[SPEAKER_01]: You stack four by a door.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'll put ten gold coins on the bar.
[SPEAKER_03]: What was his name?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm asking my first year guy, what was his name?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know, he just hired me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who hired you?
[SPEAKER_00]: That guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: What guy?
[SPEAKER_00]: The dead guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: This one opened up.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, the one that this guy opened up.
[SPEAKER_02]: He just came and said we had some coin to make.
[SPEAKER_03]: Look at the other one we have.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know his name?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I talked to the other guy, my guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Name?
[SPEAKER_02]: Same thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: I roam with him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: The bartender comes up and says, this has been very entertaining.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, if you don't mind, I'd like to get back to business.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is a respectable place.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I gave him ten gold points.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ten gold coins!
[SPEAKER_00]: The, uh... Um...
[SPEAKER_03]: Does this guy have weapons?
[SPEAKER_03]: Who, the bartender?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, no, the guy's sitting here with us.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I mean, they had clubs, basically.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's all they had was clubs.
[SPEAKER_02]: They had daggers on their sides.
[SPEAKER_03]: Drop their daggers.
[SPEAKER_03]: Make them drop their daggers.
[SPEAKER_03]: Anything they have that's valuable of any kind.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's no city watch in this place.
[SPEAKER_02]: The bartender goes, well, not really.
[SPEAKER_02]: The Marines stay on board, but once word gets out, I'm sure that Earl will send his men down.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's probably going to be a little while.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so I sit down and pour an ale of where I was before.
[SPEAKER_03]: You guys carry on.
[SPEAKER_03]: How much did they pay you?
[SPEAKER_03]: Were they gonna pay you?
[SPEAKER_03]: Did they pay you?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, to beat three Tufts like you, ten silver coins.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Bring it on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, he brings out the coins and puts them down.
[SPEAKER_03]: What other information do you think you can get from these guys?
[SPEAKER_02]: Come on, man.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just trying to get my eighth of a share.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're not actually going to take money after killing all my friends here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't care about that one.
[SPEAKER_02]: He points to the guy who gouged you up and dabb.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, you don't care about that one?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, now go.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, he was the one that... Make better choices with your life.
[SPEAKER_03]: Get up and go.
[SPEAKER_03]: You tell him to leave?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I take his, my guy's stuff, leave the silver that's sitting there on the table.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, they can't believe they're so lucky.
[SPEAKER_02]: Get up and leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: One of the guys goes, well, we did get thrown into that bargain, but at least we're alive.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wouldn't have been if it was me.
[SPEAKER_02]: They go, they get out.
[SPEAKER_02]: The bartender says to you guys,
[SPEAKER_02]: Could you at least help me move the bodies?
[SPEAKER_02]: You scared everyone else off.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think the ten gold coins covered the body moving.
[SPEAKER_02]: He picks up all ten of the gold coins.
[SPEAKER_02]: He takes that.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can't believe our lives are only worth five silver pieces.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, Gouge, did he find anything on the body?
[SPEAKER_03]: There was no information on that guy at all?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, role play.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sit down and talk to Gouge.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is there any information on that guy?
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't find anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Papers?
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice rapier, nice dagger here, and maybe about 40 gold coins left from Principality.
[SPEAKER_03]: Principalities.
[SPEAKER_03]: Anybody else in the patrons still sitting there drinking?
[SPEAKER_03]: One guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Look over at him.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know who that guy was?
[SPEAKER_03]: Not a clue.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is this the way all the hospitality works here, typically?
[SPEAKER_03]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_03]: Anybody that comes into town gets assaulted?
[SPEAKER_03]: Is this pretty normal?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, obviously the three of you are special.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, well that's good.
[SPEAKER_02]: How are we special?
[SPEAKER_02]: I have no idea.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think we should have started.
[SPEAKER_02]: People get knights in the alley, people get robbed, but...
[SPEAKER_02]: For somebody to hire Tim Tufts to come and beat on you in the bar.
[SPEAKER_03]: Fill my cup.
[SPEAKER_03]: Take it with me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's go find...
[SPEAKER_00]: I think we should go find Folsom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, let's go find Folsom and Owen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen.
[SPEAKER_01]: We spent too much time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Finish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Refill.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll walk with it out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Same here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you guys go out into the night.
[SPEAKER_02]: The docks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I guess I don't know whatever way he walked.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where do you want to look?
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, shit, where was he going?
[SPEAKER_00]: He was going to go make some merchants.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are they still out or is it back closed?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, they're merchants down on the street.
[SPEAKER_02]: Their torches lit up.
[SPEAKER_02]: The dealing seems to go all night here.
[SPEAKER_00]: People are desperate to make deals.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm on the docks.
[SPEAKER_00]: I look out in the water.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I see anything suspicious?
[SPEAKER_00]: Toli ships?
[SPEAKER_02]: What's suspicious is all the ships and the way they're docked and moored.
[SPEAKER_00]: But no new ships came in where I'm like, oh.
[SPEAKER_02]: You wouldn't even know.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, there are so many of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's just more and more.
[SPEAKER_01]: He just left a few minutes ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, we have about ten minutes of combat, if that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can you fucking track his footprints or something here?
[SPEAKER_01]: In the sand?
[SPEAKER_00]: There's way too many people walking around trying to catch his footprints.
[SPEAKER_00]: I wear high heels.
[SPEAKER_01]: A whiff of that perfume that he likes to wear.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, don't you track things?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's an endogenous cologne, thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: I say we just go into the market.
[SPEAKER_03]: Walk the market back towards the ship, I guess, in that direction.
[SPEAKER_02]: Back towards the ship or farther into where?
[SPEAKER_01]: Whichever way he left, the two of them left.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't really remember.
[SPEAKER_02]: Left or right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's not go towards the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, let's go.
[SPEAKER_00]: There we go.
[SPEAKER_02]: How long do you want to walk up the dock?
[SPEAKER_02]: Say we're walking like five minutes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you walk five minutes up through the market.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't see him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's go back in the direction.
[SPEAKER_00]: But does it keep going?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah, the island is about eight miles long and about two miles wide.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can see the Earl of Redshore's castle in the distance.
[SPEAKER_02]: What it is is a drawbridge that comes down and there's like a fortification on a walk in the middle of the sea and then another one behind it that's also connected by a bridge.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's like two castles.
[SPEAKER_02]: Smaller ones.
[SPEAKER_03]: The double bridge.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, if they did get something to trade, they're gonna need it on the ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: I see what you mean.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, we could head back towards the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean... Make sure they didn't see if those people were after, or, you know, they might have seen us go off the ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I mean... Let's go check the ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we'll turn around, I guess, and walk back in the other direction.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you turn back around and walk five, ten minutes.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're back by the bar again.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you pass the bar five minutes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you keep going.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's empty.
[SPEAKER_02]: The bodies, however, have been sacked outside.
[SPEAKER_01]: The bar?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Get to the same old fuck, yeah, all the night.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm getting laid.
[SPEAKER_03]: And all these guys, anything distinctive about them, their markings, their patches?
[SPEAKER_03]: They're Toli rats.
[SPEAKER_00]: Toli rats that... We gotta go find Owen.
[SPEAKER_00]: If he's super buddy-buddy with the Tolis, then...
[SPEAKER_00]: This shouldn't have happened, unless they heard us talking at the bar.
[SPEAKER_03]: Anybody can get a message or a way to talk to Folsom of any kind?
[SPEAKER_03]: Light an arrow, flaming arrow in the sky or some shit?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, so we're still heading back towards the ship like we're walking.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to go back to the ship?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you guys walk back to the...
[SPEAKER_02]: Cutter, and it's dark, just sitting there moored.
[SPEAKER_00]: I get on the ship.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I see anything getting on?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I mean, it seems as you left it.
[SPEAKER_00]: As we left it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, and I assume you check the cabin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nobody's there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I light a...
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, there's probably so many... Would he know where we...?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you think he would?
[SPEAKER_00]: I hope so.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's lit something, a lantern or something in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: A light of torch, sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: A lantern?
[SPEAKER_00]: A lantern that's on the, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Light up the ship a bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like the deck part.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you create, you basically take a couple of lanterns from inside the cabin and light them and hang them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right by the steering wheel.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: One up on the steerage deck and then one down on the main mast.
[SPEAKER_03]: There you go.
[SPEAKER_03]: Light the docks.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now we'll be back, I guess, now that they know that we've been here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to go back to the bar and wait.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to make my way back to the bar.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll go with it because I don't want to get separated.
[SPEAKER_01]: We should all go.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'm going to go by myself.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we'll go around that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can go wherever you want.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you should be here in case they come back.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to look for them.
[SPEAKER_01]: The halfway point is basically the bar, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's five minutes back the other way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tyrus had a hired gun anyways.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to go back by the bar and hide in shadows.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tyrus, are you going to stay at the boat?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, but not on the boat.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll be at the end of the dock.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you're on the dock guard.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, but I can see the boat, see the other way.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to stay on the deck.
[SPEAKER_02]: You'll stay on the deck.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you guys hang out at the boat.
[SPEAKER_03]: We gotta go?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.